[Music]  this is the gaito de las raccas the  andean [ __ ] of the rock  also known as tunki in the indigenous  language of quechua  widely regarded as the national bird of  peru the gaiito de las racas is native  to the andean cloud forests  their most distinct feature is their  beautiful feathers  while the male has a large crest and  bright orange plumage the female is more  modest than its counterpart with darker  brown feathers  the brilliant colors help the male stand  out when courting for a female partner  at breeding time males bob up and down  hopping around displaying their charms  females watch from branches nearby  their feathers have been an attractive  prey for the black market driving the  population down  because of droughts associated with  climate change as well as the massive  destruction of forests the future of  their longtime home is now being  threatened  this is the gaito de las rocas